It has been decided that you will be reincarnated. I
will give you the ability to cheat. Please enjoy your second life to the fullest. I have a
bad feeling. Throw this guy away in a distant forest.
Yes, I'm in a big pinch right now.
[Music]
What do you mean?  I feel a magical power from you that surpasses human breath,
but I
guess I'm the reincarnation of the Demon King, or a NEET in my previous life,
but that's right, I'm the Demon King. It's been nine years since then, Good Morning Alto. I am Gold. I
survived under the protection of the return.  Why
don't I use my cheat abilities to lazily devour sex? I'll
give my whole body to you Who the
hell am I?
[Music]
When will I be able to live a peaceful recluse life
?